one of the honorary captains for
Saturday's game for the Eagles a former
Eagle grade former ESPN analyst Ron
Jaworski jaws good to have you back how
are you today happy new year always a
pleasure being with you I am very
excited about the opportunity to win the
coin toss tomorrow are you the one
calling it what would you call if you
were calling the coin toss I would call
heads okay all right jaws gives out the
Eagles strategy for the coin toss
they're calling edge John explain to me
why the Eagles who I thought we're
probably the most balanced team I saw
this year even without Carson winds are
an underdog this weekend well it's
Carson Wentz I mean let's get real about
this he was the league MVP through 13
games of the regular season before his
injury this is a quarterback driven
League and clearly when you lose a guy
that would have been the league MVP and
you know Nick Foles is no slouch you
know people going to talk about that
2013 season with 27 touchdowns only two
interceptions and you know the great
year he had so he has the ability to
play at that high of a level but he has
not played at that level so far this
season they're gonna need Nick to step
up but I also believe they're not going
to give him the opportunity to throw the
ball 25 or 30 times they will pound the
football in this game yeah but it that's
if they're playing at home I know
Atlanta got it all together against the
Rams I'm just still surprised at
Philadelphia being the number one seed
and and they're more than just carson
wentz we can all agree carson wentz is
great but it still feels like that team
is a more balanced team than the Falcons
do playing at home so I'm just surprised
yeah I wouldn't necessarily agree with
that I think the Falcons if you look at
them the last you know month of the
season they have played very well on
both sides of the football I thought
that that win obviously had to win
against Carolina to qualify from the
Laos and going out to LA and beating a
very good Rams team you know it meant a
lot for their psyche and coming into
Philly a they they know it's gonna be
tough and you know I went back and
looked at that game last year week 10
eagles and falcons won by the eagles 20
for 15 the Eagles had that manhood
approach you know damn hey we're gonna
knock you off the ball you know all the
road graders stopped on that good
football talk you know and they did they
ran the ball for 208 yards when they had
six offensive linemen on the field for
12 snaps they averaged close to five
yards per rush I will guarantee you all
week long the Eagles have been talking
about dominance at the line of scrimmage
they will run the football they will run
it hard they will run it downhill
because they believe that's the way to
beat the Falcons explain to me what goes
on with the Steelers because I said this
15 minutes ago they lead the league in
drama and now you got Le'Veon bells
saying hey if they franchise me then
I'll sit out or retire this is on the
eve of playing the Jags you've had been
not sure if he wants to play or not you
know that you had the James Harrison
situa
I mean there's so much going on here why
why so it's dry I like that damn the
drama staff we got to start keeping that
they leave and you know you're our
coaches every week you guys those guys
crazy because that's all they talk about
is focus focus they focused on your
opponent don't give many bulletin board
material no distractions this week you
know we're three games away from a world
championship and yet guys can't help
themselves nowadays it seems and maybe
because the proliferation of all the
media we now have everyday someone slips
up and you know we take advantage that
but this it's amazing Mike Tomlin has
done just a magnificent job with that
team historically and this is this is
arguably the most talented team in the
playoffs I mean they have incredible
skill players but hey I'm still not
gonna discount those Jacksonville
Jaguars because that defensive line is
big they're tall which makes Ben react
in a different way and get the ball
sailing a little bit like you did in
that first matchup so I I think the
Steelers are terrific football team but
hey I'm not conceding this victory
against the Jaguars to him if I said you
were the quarterbacks coach for the Jags
what would be the first thing you would
do with Blake bortles and the first
thing I would do was coach him hard and
I remember being at Blake's Pro day
and I was very very impressed he could
make every throw his mechanics were very
solid
he has deteriorated mechanically and the
fundamentals of playing the position and
that's where it starts so number one he
needs to be coached hard and I believe
it's a reparation project between his
ears because when you start missing guys
on check downs and stick routes by the
tight end and backs in the flat and easy
throws that coaches call to give you
confidence and you start to miss those
it becomes a problem between the ears it
feels like he's playing for his future
eat each week certainly in the playoffs
now is that perception or do you think
that's reality if he somehow plays well
they advance is he your quarterback next
year if he doesn't play well this
weekend do you think that he's not your
your quarterback of the future it's
gonna be a very difficult decision for
the jaguars to make because the
inconsistencies in his game drive you
crazy there was a stretch this year late
in the season he was playing terrific
football and all of a sudden he just
seems to lose it for stretches in games
and except last week I mean it was they
were fortunate was the Buffalo Bills
because the Bills could not score but
it's gonna be a different animal this
week Blake bortles will happen to play
better and I'm not talking about running
for 88 yards I'm talking about throwing
the football because they're gonna need
points in this game talking to Ron
Jaworski former ESPN analyst he'll be
the honorary captain for the Eagles for
Saturday's game against the Falcons any
chance that this drama with the Patriots
affects them and their game against the
Titans no everyone try so hard Dan to
find something to rattle the Patriots
you know I mean creating headlines and
just trying to find something to get
these guys off their spot and the
Patriots or the Patriots they're
incredibly well coached they got that
you know the greatest quarterback of all
time they're versatile they can do
anything on either side of the football
they make adjustments in game halftime
as good as anyone I've ever seen and
that's what I love about the Patriots
you know that what you see in the first
quarter you're gonna see something
totally different in the fourth quarter
their ability to adapt in game is
just incredible so yeah everyone's
trying to get them off their spot but it
doesn't seem to work are you more
confident with the Vikings of the Saints
in that matchup I'm more confident
because of Drew Brees and and you know
in a quarterback driven League I love
what Case Keenum ins done I mean hey I
applaud this guy no one no one saw this
coming and and he's played at an
absolutely incredibly high level but
when you watch Drew Brees not only this
year but historically you know he makes
plays when the game is on the line and
you get in these situations they're all
four quarter games your quarterbacks got
to make plays and nothing bothers Drew
Brees the guy's the consummate
professional they have very few negative
plays or bad plays so as much as I even
like the Vikings I'm gonna give a slight
edge in this game because of Drew Brees
let me ask a non playoff question how
does this not work out is Jon Gruden
worth what the Raiders are paying him or
how does he prove his worth with the
Raiders here's a simple stat Dan in the
National Football League there are a
hundred and thirteen players making 10
million dollars or more a hundred and
thirteen you get to tell me those 113
players are more important than a coach
hey I don't think so I think a
quarterback you get money playmakers get
money the the me the coach is the guy
that deserves to be financially at least
the most rewarded for what they do so
you know we'll find out John's got a win
but I like the fact that John is back
into coaching and I said this about Dick
Vermeil when he left the game the NFL is
better when Dick Vermeil is coaching I
believe the NFL is better now that Jon
Gruden is back coaching it's better for
all of us better for the players better
for the media and you know John is a
terrific football coach and he's a
better coach now than when he left the
Tampa Bay Buccaneers
but if he's worth that what's Belichick
worth well bill should be the
highest-paid guy I mean he's you know
arguably the greatest coach of all time
it's not my money so I'd say come on
here a hundred million in and one dollar
yeah if it was my money I probably
settle for like a million do you know
melnichuk I mean really know him yes
I played against grimmer when I was
playing bill was the defensive
coordinators of New York Giants so I'm
very familiar I mean obviously the game
has changed in that time but you know
very familiar when I had to play the
mental chess game with Bill Belichick as
a player and he is one of the guys that
I literally Revere in the coaching
profession you know when I when I wrote
my book the games that changed the game
you know one of the games was the
Patriots Rams Super Bowl game where he
used what I call the bullseye approach
on Marshall Faulk and spent you know
time with Bill you know with with the
Monday Night Football he has accepted
some of my coaches of the Philadelphia
soul to come up to his training camp so
they could learn so I mean bill loves
football and I love Bill because he
loves football do you have proof that
he's funny John Bongiovi but I'll keep
those private jaws I'll see you on the
field I'll be there for NBC on Saturday
so come on what you call heads or tails
Dan I would probably go tails
oh no we disagree on that yeah yeah and
I probably go tails okay you know they
won't boo me if I get it wrong how about
for dinner I'll go tails you go heads
and I'll put a dinner on it
deal all right I'll see you saturday Ike
that's Ron Jaworski the former ESPN
analyst former Eagles quarterback and
honorary captain for Saturday's game for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show at
[Music]